يجلس محمد اسماعيل في المقهى مع اصدقائه
لمشاهده مباريات المونديال متعه حرم منها
هو والكثير من اهل العريش منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه اعوام بسبب الاحداث التي عاشتها
مدن شمال
الساعه 1:00 شغالين وفي المساء تبدو شوارع
العريش مثل اي مدينه مصريه زحام في
الشوارع والاسواق وست عوده كامله للامن
والاستقرار للمدينه
بصراحه الوضع دلوقتي تمام زي العسل
والرساله ان هذه الارض لن تصبح خاويه بعد
الان سينا لا تظل فراغ حيث ان ملئ الفراغ
الجغرافي ده بعد امن القوي طبعا لما كان
لان سينا تنميتها وحمايتها هيكون بتعميرها
وملاها بالعنصر البشري احنا مركزين في
التنميه المجتمعيه همم ده طبعا زائد عناصر
التنميه شغالين فيها ولكن معاناه ال همم
شاهدها ابنائنا في محافظه شمال سيناء
بتفرض علينا ان احنا نعوضهم عن هذه الايام
من خلال التنميه المجتمعيه اللي احنا
شغالين بها وهنا يتم العمل على قدم وساق
في تطوير ميناء العريش الميناء سيكون مركز
الانطلاق لعمليات تصدير لاوروبا وغيرها من
الاسواق هننقل محافظه شمال سيناء ان هي
تقدر كل المنتجات السنويه من الرمل
والاسمنت الابيض والاسمنت الاسود وكل
المنتجات ان احنا نقدر السفن همم في
الميناء القديم كانت السفن اللي ممكن تخش
6000 طنط ده احد اكثر وكانت الاعماق بتصل
لغايه 7 متر طبعا دلوقت مع التطوير
والقياده السياسيه شايف ان لازم تطوير
المينا ده فطبعا دي هتبقى نافذه على
العالم كله
استقراره الاوضاع كان دافعا لعوده مكثفه
لطلاب المدارس والجامعه في الاول بيبقى
المنطقه اللي فيها الجامعه كان فيها بيبقى
اكمنه فيها الكلام ده دلوقت والكلام ده مش
موجود كله بسبب ان الاستقرار رجع وان
الامن والامان رجع ومن المفترض ان تكون
عوده الاستقرار وانطلاق عمليات التنميه
بمثابه الرساله بان اعاده تعميد شمال
سيناء هي من اولويات الدوله المصريه حاليا
احمد عثمان العربيا محافظه شمال سيناء